wow I mean Shark Week just keeps getting
more and more intense every year now it
has been five years since the Meg became
a box office sensation
[Music]
and pretty much made us all weary about
swimming in the ocean again but how cool
is it that there's finally a movie about
the most famous prehistoric shark that
was 60 feet long the Megalodon so my
friends do not forget your floaties
because this is everything you need to
know before you go see meg2 the trench
let's do a recap of the Meg shall we
want to make this thing bleed so the
first film in the series 2018's The Meg
is Loosely based on the 1997 novel Meg a
novel of deep Terror in the movie Jason
Statham stars as a diver named Jonas
Taylor who specializes in deep sea
rescues he also happens to be a down and
out drunk and has to be recruited to
help save a group of scientists
including his ex-wife whose submersible
is stranded underwater now when he gets
down there he discovers what has been
causing everyone so many issues
Megalodon
he's kidding right just you know a
little prehistoric species of giant
shark called the megalodon or Meg which
is honestly such a cute name given to
such a ginormous creature now of course
after nearly dying trying to
successfully poison the Meg he
encounters an even bigger one down there
that also has to be dealt with which he
does I mean it kind of feels like Jason
Statham can save the world
[Music]
foreign
what was a pretty smart move filmmakers
actually left the door open for a sequel
at the end giving the viewer the
impression that not all the Megs are
gone done
sorry I was trying to be scary the Meg
is rotten on the Tomato Meter with
critics saying it quote lacks the genre
Thrills to make it worth diving in but
what it didn't lack was the ability to
draw large crowds pulling in over 530
million dollars at the worldwide box
office and Paving the way for a sequel
do you guys ever watch Shark Week so who
is diving in for more these puns are
just a plus today just a little bit now
for this installment we will once again
get to see Jason Statham in the lead
role as Jonas Taylor and while the rest
of the cast is mostly new faces we will
see Cliff Curtis reprise his role as Mac
who is basically like the boss of the
underwater missions and we're also gonna
get to see Paige Kennedy returning as an
engineer named DJ and Sophia Kai who
played the daughter of an oceanographer
in the first film played by Lee bing
bing now while Kai is returning Bing is
not what happened last time
you don't want to know
and I know what you're thinking all
right all right now as we know who's in
this movie but what is it about
that's the biggest snake I've ever seen
biggest bag anyone's ever seen why on
Earth would anyone jump back in the
water for more well first of all Meg to
the trench actually also happens to be
based on a Steve Alton book 1999's the
trench and the film studio synopsis
promises quote higher Heights greater
depths and multiple massive Megs I mean
that's got to be my favorite
alliteration I've ever said reading a
script we've got company this time
around Satan's Jonas Taylor is taking a
research team on an exploratory dive
into the deepest depths of the ocean you
know just for fun but not only do they
encounter more Megs and potentially
other giant prehistoric sea creatures
during this trip Jonas and his team also
find themselves going up against a
malicious mining operation that is
threatening their mission too
this place is Meg proof I mean Jonas was
always afraid of this but I was also
thinking
so let's go behind the scenes for a
second
[Music]
the mags are evolving never seen this
before they hunted in packs as far as
who brought this Meg to Life Behind the
Scenes it starts with director Benjamin
Wheatley the English filmmaker and
screenwriter brings a great combo of
skills for this movie having worked on
psychological thrillers like kill list
and a field in England along with the
adaptation high-rise with Tom Hiddleston
and the action comedy free fire with
Brie Larson I mean dude's got range and
while this is wheatley's first foray
into the world of the Meg the film
screenplay writers John hober ericober
and Dean georgaras were also credited
for writing the first installment so you
gotta love a little continuity baby
plus we cannot forget producer
extraordinaire Lorenzo de bonaventura I
mean with a name like that who could
forget him he's going to be behind the
sequel after also producing the first
and he is best known for producing the
GI Joe and Transformers film series so I
mean goes without saying he knows a
thing or two about money making action
flicks am I right everybody might get to
the station
Pink Floyd
all right my friends that's everything
you need to know before you go see Meg
to the trench in theaters August 4th
mark your calendars my name is as Perez
thanks for watching and be sure to rate
and review this film at
rottentomatoes.com